Let's think about
the different use
cases for credit default swaps.
So let's say that I have
some company over here,
and it's given a
BB credit rating.
And this rating, of course,
comes from a credit rating
agency, sometimes called a
ratings agency or a rating
agency.
I've seen it every
different way.
So this would be like Moody's or
Standard and Poor's or whatever
else.
And they look at this company,
and they look at its business,
they look at its balance
sheet, and they say, OK,
it's not super safe, but
it's not super risky either.
We give it a BB rating.
And let's say that there's
an investor over here who
wants to lend money
to this company.
So he might lend them
some money and get
some interest in return.
But this investor doesn't
like this level of safety.
He wants to make sure
that he's made whole
even if this company
goes out of business.
So he can go to a writer
of a credit default swap,
and the most famous of
those credit default
swap writers is or was AIG.
And he'll say,
hey, AIG, I'm going
to pay you a little
bit every year.
You could view that as
an insurance premium.
And in exchange,
you are essentially
going to ensure me in the case
of a default by this company.
And what we already said,
it's a little bit shady
because it was not
regulated like insurance.
So AIG did not have
to set anything aside.
And what was
powerful here for AIG
is that the rating
agencies continued
to give AIG a very high rating.
So let's say it had a AA rating.
So despite the fact
that it kept taking
on all these liabilities,
the credit rating agency
says, hey, we'll
still give you a AA.
So they were able to use
this AA rating to keep
writing these contracts,
to keep writing insurance
and not setting anything aside,
and essentially just getting,
almost you could
view it, free money
with having to pay
the piper eventually.
Now this is one scenario.
Another scenario is
maybe an investment bank
creates some type of
special purpose entity
or some collateralized debt
obligation right over here.
And they have their
different tranches.
And maybe for the senior
tranche over here,
just so that they can sell them
to pension funds who can only
buy AA rated debt,
pension funds.
The investment bank goes
to AIG and says, hey,
can this entity right over
here buy credit default swaps?
Can we enter into credit
default swap agreements
on you, so that in case any
of this stuff were to default,
you will also insure that?
And once we do that,
then a rating agency.
So this is a security.
This is a senior tranche of a
collateralized debt obligation
now, the senior tranche, and
now that that senior tranche
is essentially insured by
AIG, a credit rating agency,
once again, will assign
this a AA rating.
Even though this
thing might be made up
of a bunch of sub-prime
mortgages and all of the rest,
although it is a senior tranche
so it'll be made whole first,
but now pension funds can
buy this type of thing.
The last use case is maybe you
have a hedge fund out here who
doesn't want to lend
anybody any money,
but is convinced that a whole
bunch of these companies, maybe
this company over here or maybe
this company over here, that
has some other rating.
So this is another company.
This hedge fund is convinced
that these companies are going
to default on their
debt, that there's
going to be a credit
crisis of some kind.
Well, then this hedge fund can
enter into credit default swap
agreements to essentially
get insurance,
but not having
anything to insure.
It's like getting car insurance
on someone else's driving
or someone else's
car, and you kind of
are starting to hope that they
have to have a car accident.
Because now if this guy
has a credit default
swap on this company
right over here,
despite the fact that they
didn't lend out to them,
the hedge funds is going to
pay a little bit every year
and get the insurance.
And they are essentially going
to hope that this company goes
out of business,
because if it does,
then they're going to get
the insurance payment.
They're going to get the same
payment that this investor
would have, but they would have
never had to lend the money.
So you could use
it as a side bet,
you could use it as a way of
making lower-rated securities
all of a sudden acceptable
to pension funds,
or you could use it as a
straight-up way of insuring
debt that you're
lending to someone else.